my vision of Africa is in Africa in 2014
which is fully integrated which means
the original blog should be working
together is one African economy this
should be done in a framework that is
driven by entrepreneurship that is
driven by the ICT infrastructure that is
driven by science and technology that is
driven by value addition and
beneficiation I see in Africa and 20 40
which is fully and completely
independent of donna's in other ways to
get there we need a strategy that is
investment-driven that is export driven
so that Africa is not dependent on
donors so this Africa will require that
some of the best minds in Africa must be
involved in the public sector in other
words we must have touched technocratic
capacity into the leadership of Africa
we can't achieve the Africa I want to
see if we leave the leadership in Africa
to mediocrity and those who thought
capacity so we need a share of some of
the best minds to move in from business
in key public office from academia into
public office we want in Africa which is
a globally competitive economy a
peaceful and prosperous continent